and that includes the three-act
structure because if you yeah and but
with a three-act structure you know i'm
not so rigid that i have to say
everything is three acts i might have
six acts
i might have you know in broken promises
which was a movie i made about the
united nations on its 60th anniversary i
also followed
several different characters and i
wanted to tell
i wanted to tell a story of
of uh
peacekeepers through people that were
affected on the front lines of these
missions so i wanted to get enough i
wanted to go through
personal
stories i wanted to find personal
stories that would uh illuminate larger
issues like oil for food or
the the massacre in srebanitsa or the
genocide rwanda i wanted to find people
who were actually there on the ground
to tell me their their view of what
happened so
you know you're always trying to relate
it to personal
stories
large topics but if you can relate to
personal stories that will help so it's
not always sometimes it's not three acts
you know in in a conventional dramatic
way sometimes it's six sacks it depends
on how many characters you have and
perhaps the entire movie is three acts
but you sliced it so that little
characters can come in and leave and and
they their story can wrap up
and it's soon going toward
a larger three-act frame on that united
nations movie was here was what it was
created to be
in 1945 which was the world's workshop
for peace
largely created by the united states
what happened in act 2
lots of good things happen with unicef
and what have you in feeding the poor
but lots of bad things happen too
with scandals and
peacekeeper rape scandals and oil oil
for food again and and these various
problems and corruption so that's act
two and act three is are we just going
to burn the building down no how do you
how do you try to fix it what are the
ideas to try to bring them back to that
original ideal of 1945 to be the world's
workshop for peace so those were within
that three-act structure the larger one
i had multiple
you know those tinier acts within that
as i followed these characters you know
as they as they show us how they've
related to these various u.n
programs
you